happy st. Patrick's says a happy st.
Patrick's Day to you you used to own the
bar in Minneapolis that sold more
whiskey than any other bar in the entire
world that's correct I have a challenge
for you you are sitting next to George
bori he's a senior strategist at Wells
Fargo but that's not important right now
what is important is that he is a scotch
drinker you sell him right now
well you know us the Scots God love them
they will be barrel-aging watered if it
wasn't for the Irish inventing whiskey
all those years ago and so the smooth
Irish whiskey it is the coming thing the
taste profile wait now it's the coming
thing or it's the arrived thing your you
are part of what made it happen in
America right this is correct yes so
what is it how do you sell I mean you
just sold it to George but sell it again
to me how do you make this distinction
to people who are used to thinking about
sort of Peter fees Scotch or have their
bourbon you know this is blended it's a
little more you have you have different
options of how to cask it so you're
selling a wide range of products right
well to ginger's Irish whiskey really
came as a result of my work in the pubs
and interaction with consumers every
single day and looking at what is it
that the movement towards craft etc and
we looked at how do we get people to
drink Irish whiskey during the time when
I was a kid no one would be caught dead
drinking Irish whiskey to be blunt it
was what bums drank not necessarily
Irish bums bums of all persuasions yet
you're at the forefront of changing the
psychology with Beaman and with the
others that have bought into to gingers
to gingers is for Olivia Sterns I mean
come on it's a girl absolutely enough
it's not people who will not drink
Irish whiskey thank you to convert
people I do
drink Irish whiskey right right open the
bottle we're not allowed to open the
bowl it doesn't smell nearly as toxic
drink to gingers at Ralph Lauren's new
polo bar over by the st. Regis Hotel you
know this is an entrepreneurial endeavor
to gingers yesterday whisky is the
grassroots out in the field I go around
the United States Hanrahan selling
getting people to taste too gingers
Irish whiskey
whether it's knees or whether it's in
our trademark cocktails big ginger and
stevia the bucket indoors but I need to
point something out here oh sorry go
ahead Julia you two kids these days I
mean you know go to nightclubs an order
bottles of whiskey when and where are
people drinking it well not kids but
obviously people responsible age
etcetera but nobody under 21 drinks
correct but what we're looking at is if
you look at the Crafts movement where
there is beer food etc Irish whiskey if
this is distill twice it's aged four
years we age of next bourbon barrels and
it's really about a taste profile and
about bringing people into a category
away from vodka that's my god does it
convert into vodka soda I think well
obviously the taste profile because we
distill it twice it stands up better in
a cocktail and that's again we
trademarked cocktails who has trademark
cocktails we do what's interesting here
is that you're going after the dark and
stormy market the gin and tonic market
this is right of an afternoon drink in
the summer I feel like we have to
disclose something right now which is
that Karen and I yesterday discovered
that we were cousins in fact literally I
am NOT making this up we are both from
the same town in County Mayo Bali Hana
says five thousand souls in it and there
are Greeley's not arrests than five
thousand souls but there are Greeley's
there and some of them married into your
family this is actually the Greely House
I think we have a picture that I took in
2012 but I mean this is pointing towards
there's me in front of the Greely House
in Bali hon it's not a very big place
but here's my question as you're selling
you used to sell Irish whiskey to Irish
Americans when you look at the branding
on to gingers it's not Irish it all know
you're it's a different thing you're
selling out the modern Irish
whiskey and again - ginger named after
my mother and my aunt yes and it is
about fired up and it is about going
left when people go right and honestly
we are the modern Irish alright we're
going to drink in a second we got to get
out of